en este vídeo quiero darles una
introducción básica muy breve al
concepto de probabilidad probabilidad
que es una palabra que casi seguro ya
han escuchado antes pero espero que este
vídeo nos ayude o nos ayude a clarificar
un poco qué está pasando así que bien
imaginemos empecemos imaginando que
tengo una moneda y que esta moneda es
una moneda justa eso quiere decir que la
posibilidad de que caiga de un lado o el
otro es exactamente la misma no tiene
ningún truco que hace que digamos
siempre caiga águila por ejemplo así que
aquí tengo mi moneda esto es mi intento
de dibujar un águila así que de este
lado tengo águila y de este lado tengo
sol quizás ustedes hablen de cara o cruz
pero la idea es la misma así que lo que
voy a hacer es echarme un volado con mis
amigos volado voy a arrojar la moneda al
aire y ver que cae y me pregunto cuál es
la probabilidad de obtener águila en el
volado lo voy a
y probabilidad de obtener allí la ahora
bien ya desde aquí desde la pregunta nos
podemos dar una idea de lo que significa
probabilidad es como un modo de manejar
un evento de manejar y entender un
evento que es fundamentalmente aleatorio
yo no tengo ningún control acerca de si
va a caer águila o si va a caer sol otro
modo de pensar en esto es que es una
medida de la frecuencia de que tantas
veces que hay águila o que tantas veces
que hay sol voy a regresar a esto en un
segundo ok entonces la forma en la que
normalmente nos introduce en el concepto
de probabilidad es definirlo como el
número de casos posibles número de casos
casos posibles
y esto va a dividir al número de casos
número de casos que satisfacen
satisfacen
pasen mis condiciones mis condiciones
y eso suena como que puede ser algo
enredos o pero en realidad es un
concepto muy simple
en este caso mis condiciones es
simplemente que salga águila así que
bien volviendo a la pregunta original
cuál es la probabilidad de obtener
águila en el volado pues cuántos casos
posibles tengo estoy asumiendo que la
moneda no puede caer digamos de lado y
quedarse ahí parada o que haya águila ok
sol así que tengo dos casos posibles dos
casos posibles y cuáles de esos
satisfacen mis condiciones mi condición
es que cada águila de modo que sólo uno
de esos casos me favorece el caso en el
que la moneda cae en gallina así que la
probabilidad de que caiga águila es de 1
entre 2 y nosotros sabemos que un medio
de algo equivale a decir que es el 50
por ciento de algo otro modo de pensar
en esto es considerar el experimento de
echar un volado así que vamos a llamar
esto un experimento sé que quizás estén
acostumbrados a pensar en experimentos
como cosas
pero en este caso mi experimento va a
ser echarme un volado así que bien la
probabilidad lo que me dice es que si yo
repitiera este experimento muchas muchas
veces mil veces o un millón de veces o
un billón de veces o un trillón de veces
la probabilidad me dice qué porcentaje
de los resultados espero que sean a mi
favor qué porcentaje va a cumplir con la
condición que yo especifique eso me mira
la probabilidad por ejemplo imaginemos y
de hecho este es un experimento
divertido que los invito a hacer
imaginemos que tenemos una caja en la
que metemos no sé 100 monedas ya
quitamos la caja entonces eso podemos
pensarlo como que estamos haciendo 100
volados simultáneamente cuando la caja
la dejemos de agitar entonces lo que
esperaríamos de acuerdo con la
probabilidad es que aproximadamente la
mitad de las monedas sean águila y la
otra mitad
eso es lo que me dice la probabilidad si
repito un experimento muchas muchas
muchas veces qué porcentaje de los
resultados espero que sean favorables
para mí y claro por ejemplo con los
volados existe la posibilidad de que
después de echarme si embolados me hayan
salido puras águilas aunque la
probabilidad de que esto suceda es
extremadamente baja pero mientras más
volados me eche sin me hecho mil volados
o un millón de volados entonces la
frecuencia con la que obtengo águila va
a ser aproximadamente el 50 por ciento
quizás este modo de pensar en
probabilidad sea un poco más confuso
generalmente es más fácil primero pensar
en probabilidad de este modo del modo de
número de casos que satisfacen mis
condiciones entre el número de casos
posibles pero bueno hagamos otro ejemplo
típico imaginemos ahora el experimento
de lanzar un dado así que déjenme dibujo
aquí mi lado un dado de 6 caras porque
luego hay dados un poco extraño
aquí tengo uno aquí estaría el 2 y acá
estaría el 3 entonces bien el
experimento consiste en lanzar un dado
cuáles son los casos posibles que puede
pasar se había enfundado pues lo que
puede pasar es que salga 1 2 3 4 5 ó 6 y
de hecho si es un dado justo que no
tiene ninguna trampa de nuevo entonces
la probabilidad de que caiga 1 2 3 4 5 o
6 es exactamente la misma pero bien
entonces qué pasa si me pregunto qué
pasa si me pregunto por la probabilidad
de obtener un digamos un 3
6 de lanzar el dado y que el resultado
sea 3 o 6 pues el número de casos
posibles es como decía seis casos me
tiene que salir alguno de estos seis
números y el número de casos que
satisfacen mis condiciones es pues os
sale 3 o sale 6 esos son los únicos
casos que me sirven entonces la
probabilidad sería 2 entre 6 o lo que es
lo mismo un tercio
ahora bien qué pasa si pregunto qué pasa
si pregunto
cuál es la probabilidad de arrojar un
dado y obtener un 3 y un 6
pues de nuevo el número de casos
posibles es 6 pero como sólo estoy
lanzando el dado una vez no me puede
pasar que me salga 3 y simultáneamente 6
estos eventos son mutuamente excluyentes
así que en realidad él no puede pasar
que me salga 3 y 6 simultáneamente
formalmente aquí iría un 0 y la
probabilidad sería 0 pero no quiero
confundirlos mucho con esto ya veremos
esto más adelante déjenme lo tacho
olvídense quizás de esto
vamos a hacer un último ejemplo vamos a
considerar la probabilidad probabilidad
de rodar un número par de sacar un
número par al lanzar un dado cuáles son
los casos posibles de nuevo tengo solo
seis casos posibles 1 2 3 4 5 6 y de
estos de estos los únicos números pares
son 2 4
6 así que tengo 3 números pares entre
seis números posibles al arrojar un dado
así que la probabilidad de arrojar un
dado y obtener un número par es de un
medio